if you want to email me or get in
contact with me as Alison said I do own
the domain don't you sister calm the
reason I bought that domain was that I
wanted to make the disclaimer very
obvious right those ideas for little use
on by RC by RC handle is be UTC and
given enough time on channel last
questions which are like how much II was
really stupid thing and I'll say well
this tiger and this people say please
don't show the newbies I do today oh
yeah what I'm do you TC don't lose this
code now one comment is sometimes I see
people become really quickly and 30h on
the end well the guy dr. Dutch and did
find a way to Dutch into it so if you
ever actually call me Dutch it's okay
I'm from Texas
don't use this coat Hoff's additionally
the recycle domain will select the
create blog at seriously not though
pieces go calm before bus but there's
love really weird and wild wacky stuff a
couple of things that you might see
times with that said or a jump into the
presentation I'm going to do it kind of
Mister Rogers file so I can take a
computer rock songs is a window manager
colossal and I don't like slideshows so
what I do when I get presentation is I
like virtual desktops and I use the
names that virtual desktops for each of
the sections of the presentation so
these are sections are get seats nuts
it's an email from me that back that
works the potholes that stop that people
have stopped the frantic pace that never
done so I'm going to show you about
seven things that we really should do to
really want the wacky stuff plus I don't
have anything better my life to do then
come up with these ideas and I have more
personal more email
people at the fuse must question and
that's how fun for this box it is to
print out a list of numbers from one to
something and if the numbers were select
three prints outfits in this little f5
resembles and if it was about three to
five years of business and this is the
basic test to see if people understand
that when it bounces why decided could
be way to generalize this class as a
single line of code
so this is what looks like and you can
see this is responsible take any set of
terms and it's generalized and is
actually infinite sequence of this West
terms in one single I have three look at
this really carefully you can see I use
three pieces from base wide intervals
and these crazy things so use
combinations of here I need to chain
that formidable if you ever work with me
and I say we should just chain off
considerable for this you know something
is immense
and you actually pass in the terms which
you wanted to run initially Pascal
scribe well I thought when they pick a
new Pascal struggle that a single line
as well so here's kind of the extent
that we should be doing a single line
there's actually one period of common
pattern here that comes up a lot in my
code which is a pattern of ten lines
which is the single line of code can you
write a generator that gives you
paralyzed views of a sequence so you
have sequential
1 2 2 & 3 3 4 from within fashion and it
turns out I've written this enough times
I can probably write it for them so
looks something like this from their
tools import i spiced tea and ice and it
looks like this it's a really good
school on Jeannie and I sip star I slice
G so you can see Python is well known
for language tends to be very easy to
understand but if you want you can also
make it mostly in rural Tennessee step
one is to see how much do we really
stick into my life because you can think
for a clue if you have multiple
statements you need to put new life and
so you can say well I've also heard
trying set so one thought I've been
working on is this things like how can
you come that's common powers of my box
or single lock so this is an example of
how you can take this tight set pattern
and write it in a single lock so this
works I accept looks like a single line
and it turns out that it actually works
but the one exception that you can't get
the value of the actual exception option
don't pay too much attention this is
really please don't ever do this in
practice there is double for me so
that's bad because
that's a person here is that worse so
Python 3.4 introduced a new keyword
yields from amendment to existing
problem and one thing that find us also
before it's a very break of our great
understanding the syntax maybe you can't
do a lot of weird stuff at the syntax
some people do with many languages
however it's letting some pretty wild
stuff combining features so what they I
decided to combine a generator
expression deal from and I ended up with
this number two eg at Milton's impulse
is angry knowing the stuffs so in good
basis it's the exact same thing as this
X for X next for X and X to take a list
with number eleven planet and it's the
exact same thing as chain up on their
own but it goes to show them through a
really diverse you really try even with
a regular language like Python you can
abuse the syntax and come up with some
things which are totally true
I've shown this first one to a couple
for developers and even they were a
limit stuff that's the let did so if
you're evil enough you can do it and
that's why override tonight so I started
playing around inside
but there's there's a you can remove
this you can actually have any one day I
was before I was chatting with him and I
my troubles
we have return statements anywhere you
want and I make classes and the really
neat thing is the body of the class is
actually a bit of executable code and
what produces is the is the dictionary
of the contents of the class so what you
can actually do is you can do some class
like an anonymous namespace or just
their basements Rachel a lot of
computation you can explicitly export
the parts of the class if you want to
export so the class might be able to see
internal forms of type of work that you
wouldn't be able to visualize on several
times so that's something you can do why
would ever want to do this I don't know
but you can't let's go on to so I give I
give it a couple talks and last few
years last year I gave fifteen concepts
seven conferences and black boxes nobody
ever asked me what countries and I'm
trying to guys
I'll tell you what they are Canada the
US Finland Spain Texas I wish every time
I come back to the US have to fly abroad
I wish I wish I wish the passport guy in
Newark or JFK will ask me are you an
American or what country car and I have
response plan if you ask where you were
very I'll say those two on the texture
the answer or Obama say I'm from Texas
that said one of the presentations I
like to give is on donors and there's a
lot of beard about backstopping to
attendees here's the example I call this
stock because please don't ever do this
but you can turn a ship it works in
about 20 lines of code you can see this
we're already 693 so this is 2600 months
of really mad ideas you can create your
own type system on top of jell-o's
so you could do something like
you do this you can visit other objects
and you can little tag on them and that
tag is a time and using that you can
implement something that I called
cooperative multiple dispatch namely
generators by virtue of being late allow
you to see the entire sequence of
cognitive computation so in call
function after folks after a function
the outer functions only see the results
of the inner function when you do a
generator like at IGN a to do composer
is generous is the other gender which
means the outermost herbs is the entire
computation as a consequence if you can
add some typing and some dispatch what
you can do is you can do automatic
optimizations on top of sequences of
genders or in this example this example
I have F G H and some of these
generators are tagged in such a way that
if they see each other thanks for took
they'll be - us so in this computation F
G and H compose or result only one of
them be called where they do that
another way if you construct your
computation as a secretary generators
the Jenners can see each other and then
remove redundant computations they could
swamp themselves out before optimized
version so and achieve and swap
themselves out for and combine fuse FG
and all sorts of weird stuff and it
turns out it takes about 20 Mexico so
that's something that
you're going to do a lot of those kind
of things in my club sometimes systems
using its this jacket is distance
you shouldn't this comes up a lot on the
type of IRC channel it's a really
terrible idea but you could and maybe it
might be the problem
let's go eat this is a long long time
and I have to question what is called
difficult Python and the reason I name
is was I have a friend who is another
speaker is being in my lovin that we
speaking find out within this weekend as
well and he once asked me if I'd ever
have my super simple my friends from
Spain and I couldn't tell them saying a
bison burger so I came up with this to
make a very handsome but you can see
these files are exactly the same they
import something from this one called in
the apartment at result so you think if
I were to about these files they should
have done the same thing but no they
don't
it turns out in Python there's a really
nice safe DiPaola call it works it works
you can write in work where we do import
something from my module I'll give you a
different thing on week one where
depending on what I feel so you could be
seeing your terminal saying from Jamie's
employment something and I'll give you
whatever answer I want to and different
answers at different times to really
really quite crazy 51 lines of I
actually initially intended this
other languages inside modules so that
you could have a similar background I've
been another language and then what each
other
riots and then maybe results available
to try to interpret that of course we
turn out to be a little trickier than I
thought but I thought was an interesting
thing where you can create modules that
return different results and I work on
some mechanisms by which to affect them
so the other things in it from do they
work into a module B and I work with
that they will continue the infection
throughout the entire system so that's
what that you can do it at any people
and there's actually one use case that
I've seen that when this is kind of
useful you have a bunch of different
modules with the common dependency of
your system except one of the modules is
dependent on version 1.0 of the most
version 1.5 and what you can do is you
could have the module that depends on
one four five get the different so you
can do some very surgical
it's very surgical fixes in your code
using the same so for almost nothing
this is my stop and because it reminds
me of their comm you should be feeling
just about so that's you stop you know
how one has explicit self meaning
whatever when you're writing about
python class is suspended you type death
fugu cell phone always thought that was
kind of lame I thought could you have
that stuff somehow materialize without
having talent that turns out there's a
couple different ways to this I try to
look for ways to email and enter when
you type operating would have a name
being loaded in the context of this in
the first place from that's low very low
man
because yeah so you can see all of the
object and then one do is I go in there
and I grab the pipe object and I fit a
couple bits and then once I've done that
I can write a simple decorator that
gifts the gifts of my code
and once you do that you can write throw
that looks like this
where you can see it's using underscore
style - more but that has to be defined
anywhere and it's been injected
automatically into the closure by means
of this decorator and a little bit of
interpreter back one thing that I
thought doing was if you really wanted
to you could maybe find out so one thing
I was loaded I spent 20 minutes looking
a huge amount that so I restart the
notebooks I have said that 20 minutes
again really well and I absolutely done
from future corporate function so every
time I want to print something I have to
put practice on that but I want to see
quite important and I supposed to
behavior back to click without the
parentheses really well so I spoken to
the Python server to see it as possible
turns out don't believe it's possible
because there's no work that you have of
how to debug into into the different
flags that are set and but this is a
similar idea to something else I've been
trying to just you might be able to make
modifications monkey passion to the
madness of some interpreter by getting a
handle lots of questions and then going
into them and create them assembly stuff
so they Java somewhere else and then
they jump back to you and it's a part of
the next time you have which is to build
the perfect proxy without any seeker
interpretation which would actually have
to patch the built-ins that you use we
respected that you couldn't match the
voltage spike or right that somebody
else might have found a handle so you
actually go into the cito that your
[ __ ] is using and actually send so
that's something that might be a future
talk with this engine but you can see
you can kind of do these things in pipe
off and surprisingly enough this works
any Python 2.7 Mac Windows OSX elemental
lords the only thing that won't work on
is if you're using a pipeline where the
formatting of the PI optics has changed
which means you're using Python 3 I
thought - this will work with my
function for us so let's go to finals
and this one's a real practice this were
able to route so I can put a talk called
and Bennigsen back I was at PyCon sweden
month or two ago I wasn't did my talk
and I recently backed up my future and I
forgot the tricks for other plausible so
I was a day of talk I said that I took
LS my directory where I keep this talk
was all that leg is broken sentence so
it turns out I didn't have any of my top
of me and I was
I was some distance away from home with
none of my phone so I had to rewrite
this entire thing from scratch and I was
able to do that was a really interesting
and very simple approach to a problem
that we have so we know that we have
extension modules in so you can write in
C correct extension and I extension
module will do whatever you want we also
know there's this thing called the very
high level and the pure event in height
which means you can have a seat bro
Grameen could have better opportunities
can you write extension module that's
been some Python server into a Python
and you can't now I question your
comment because I did it a couple
different ways somebody I didn't my talk
I speak why run tunes and I told them
because somebody said you could kind of
actually camera yet this is something
that I developed during my see kind of
office hours
there's a reason why only you should
show up is lot of really cool stuff
going on so here's the latest approach
the latest ones with Grayson the first
approach was just try to embed a high
context culture and you can't do that
because when you're trying to compile an
extension module but I thought she had a
threesome open class so I quote a source
editor so that all the top three names
have pine freedom and
and you could do I didn't like that
because it allows you to essentially
modify enormous number faster package
well it turns out you can do this thing
called our till date Deepak
what this means is if I watch over you
can go you can load charges you can
learn other levels and one of those
languages could be another potential and
you can load it dynamically in such a
way that the names in the library are
not visible and do not consent the names
program that's so that's it works I'll
keep mine means it means that the
roadshow library should only resolve
things which resulting on the truck what
this allows you to do is to create a
program that affects multiple languages
this is an example of inventing multiple
Python - or else we'll Python 3 tubers
in the same process so here I have two
or three Python - and - if you fight on
three days rental sequences
unfortunately it requires me to copy
around shared objects and another person
of this I'm working on where you
patchily person again those are not a
couple times so you'll think that I came
up this was all the fight back
something really need to have to come up
I wanted to the end goal of this was to
embed Python one control Python to
Python 3 but you can't nobody summer
so I think I'm the only person who's
ever built a shared object I thought one
point why it took me about half the
playwright's and fix the make box you
can actually build a shared object and
then I was able to build a Python one of
em in Python 2 with the step to get back
the eventual Python 3 it's still rumors
so there we go I've given you six really
bad ideas all pretty much on theme
there's a couple really bad ideas I
supposed to be my comments and i wanted
to talk very quickly about why and
there's a real Intimus i have found that
your program is enormous advantage to
testing about as far as you possibly can
and the results of that maybe convince
ourselves or live naturally in trouble
or creating a portal that returns
different results every time we push
them about us
and you go a little bit too far and you
do something that man was not meant to
do you learn something deeper about a
system and you pick up techniques and
tools that end up actually being useful
and effective for build robots each one
of these cases I found there's always an
opportunity to use them all so that game
in order to solve a much less ridiculous
or much less provocative much less
queenless problem using the same
techniques I wouldn't know how to solve
those problems
I wouldn't know how to use the portals
to do some of this
important if I didn't if I had gone home
and so I would encourage all of you to
test the batteries to see what you can
do and what you kept you no matter what
you cannot do is also extremely
beneficial because finding playing these
real barriers in the language people
understand power construction because
you understand what is possible but it's
easy to do or less hard to do I think it
makes you a better programmer each other
so that's a motivation for this talk I
think I've shown you a couple of really
bad recap very quickly here it is don't
write everything about life please want
to give this is I agree with the syntax
using yield from where it doesn't belong
this is playing with each other and just
looking around and seeing official file
and doing things like the decorators and
returns outside of functions this is
playing with the mechanisms of Python
sort of higher-level mechanisms like
type generators that can then modify
other computations this is using some of
the safety valve I thought gives you in
order to implement very strategic and
very searchable or change to the
language I think they walk around with
an import mechanism this is
this is how you can actually modify the
quarterback sugar and some playing
around so the initial thing around 22
first week at one time and also a little
bit of a pike book for free as well and
finally this is the solution to the Jill
instead of multi prophecy just a bit
multiple observers to same process with
some of those shared objects are but
that anything is and how things work if
it's the actual really sea level so
that's my talk that's of our patients
Tokyo Twitter I want to hear it from you
guys I'm straight
some of these things like almonds which
may be produced in some ways
somebody would just take the bike yeah
which of the two is you could write up
if you could read if you could write a
opposite that past afraid about sow the
seeds out so that the actual evaluations
did different things have their own
records so they really really want so is
your probably harder but it would be
good uses techniques to rank main office
caterers or many fliers I don't know
beautiful crisp language with issues but
she likes cutting fun that syntax was
very own positions in the language of
law and he could write extremely elegant
program
and
what is something you would write
program
and one last thing about Python says
intended to be a language then you
should be able to be and it should be
able to understand without having to
spend too much time too much it supposed
to be very easy week but you can see
even some cases that that's how did you
start out like pushing the boundaries of
the language they seem like to be the
result of a but a lot of time spent for
the pushing the language to pushing the
boundaries of some of the first things
you did so well so the first steps for
this were one of the first steps was a
friend of mine was interviewing for a
job that invited so guess how you write
it was a nice he said I write my story
bathroom and I thought well if you're
saying go to one mom just that just play
around rather you make sure yes and
these will come to a hard interview
where we have time off to them we have
as much time as you want but not that
hard to do look to me and so the
challenge is how people better or
shorter or more office caterer
why that one line is going to be a
challenge especially how you express
them in a single line without
then I got word one lands up opposite
too easy so I went to think of
one-liners I went to syntax prophesy
regular when I got bored with that I
said with each other and then I'm kind
of working each other stuff out so I
think I'm gonna go do some [ __ ] rapid
assembly and then once I get bored with
that I might just destroy the world so I
don't know but it was it was essentially
seeing just a little time
we're there any other questions did
y'all enjoy sitting in some of these
things I might post some of these online
if the government will let me but there
are export restrictions on this piece of
code so they may not be available some
Texas I wanted to thank all of you for
coming out I have to leave graciously
Jenny there's an awesome awesome night
we heard awesome - Alison - think we're
going to hear from your alliance right
now I wish I could stay to hear from all
of you guys but I really wanted you to
share some of your experiences and some
of the things that you tried to push the
boundaries or some bad idea
thank you very much